I don't know if you know this but it is
almost 20 years since the first NSYNC
album came out 1998 here right are we
doing something special yeah there's
we're doing something I know I don't
know if I can announce it yeah yeah
visit et we can announce it all right I
mean I'll go ahead and mount it right
now we are coming out with a really cool
vinyl edition of our Christmas album
because it's coming up on the 20 years
of that album and so we're doing a
release the Christmas album vinyl for
those vinyl lovers out there I think
it's gonna be really cool and then we're
gonna be getting our star on the Walk of
Fame to share at some point oh five of
you yeah mm-hmm and you will all be
there I'll be there we just have to
decide on a date we are terrible at
planning things yeah and it's probably
hard to get the five of you all together
that and you know amber five guys so you
know for us to make a decision about
anything is really hard so we just need
to like do it you know so hopefully
maybe around Christmas time you know
it's coming there it'll be nice
I think fans are going to have an end
it'll be fun it'll be fun to see
everybody again well and get our star
this year and then we'll have a nice you
know release of some NSYNC music and
yeah well that have any new no it will
not it's a strict re-release of the
Christmas album on vinyl because people
didn't really want it on vinyl will it
come out then like this come out for
this Christmas okay for this Christmas
yeah it'll be a whole Christmas thing
and have you guys talked like I do have
a group change don't we do we talk daily
yeah oh my love you let's eat let's
bring you the texture yes I would have
to shoot you if you saw the stuff we
wrote to each other all we do is bag on
each other all day long ah Oh we'll find
you know pictures on Instagram of us
from the 90s and yeah so we're always
giving it to each other better Justin's
hair mainly Joey Joey gets a lot of the
brunt of our jokes um so yeah it's fun I
mean those guys are my brothers and so
we act like immature brothers all the
time also Britney's lifetime oh okay
this weekend have you guys talked about
it in your group text
no God no we haven't actually that's
thank you yeah I need to bring that up
yourself I'll tell you what they say
[Music]